Ordinary life is getting a lot more expensive.
In an Fox News poll, 70 percent of registered
voters said recent increases in grocery prices
had caused hardship for them and their families,
and 68 percent gave that response about gas
prices. Almost three in ten described the
hardships as serious. In the poll, 86 percent
of registered voters said they were extremely or
very concerned about inflation and higher prices.
Concern about it topped the list of the 13 items
the pollster examined. Ninety-four percent
of Republicans, 83 percent of independents,
and 78 percent of Democrats were concerned.
The administration suggests that inflation
increases are likely to be temporary, but the
polls suggest that Americans aren’t buying
it – at least right now. In a late July CNBC
survey, 51 percent were pessimistic about the
economy and the outlook, the highest level since
2015. Just 22 percent in the poll gave the economy
positive marks and were optimistic. Joe Biden
is clearly losing ground on handling of the economy.
His honeymoon is clearly over.
How worried are you about inflation?
Let us know in our poll. And also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.